[Music]  these  visions you have  [Music]  there of pain  suffering death  train yourself to let go  [Music]  of everything you fear to lose  learn to know the dark side of the force  and you will be able to save your wife  from a certain death  [Music]  i'm not the jedi i should be  i want more  [Music]  they know your power will be too strong  to control  [Laughter]  [Music]  uh  i would like to thank ridge wallets for  sponsoring this video  these wallets are light sleek compact  and  designed to easily fit in your front  pocket  unlike the traditional wallet which is  large and bulky  the ridge wallet can hold up to 12 cards  plus has room for cash  there's over 30 colors and styles  including carbon fiber  and burnt titanium so get 10 off today  with free  worldwide shipping and returns by going  to rich.com  tara or using a link in the description  and guys don't forget to enter code tara  to get your discount  thanks for watching